una vez más se recomienda a los
franceses no viajar el martes ya que los
sindicatos volvieron a convocar a huelga
la compañía Nacional de ferrocarriles
estima que sólo funcionarán entre el 20
y el 50% de los trenes de alta velocidad
tgv y aún A menos enlaces regionales en
París Solo dos servicios no tripulados
de 14 líneas de metro funcionarán con
normalidad muchos padres tendrán que
teletrabajar y las escuelas estarán
cerradas pero todo por un motivo la
mayoría de los franceses se opone a la
reforma de las pensiones algo respecto a
lo que la primera ministra se mantiene
firme no ya no es negociable la
jubilación a los 64 años así como un
periodo de cotización más largo son los
compromisos a los que Hemos llegado son
necesarios para un sistema equilibrado
el proyecto de ley ya está en el
parlamento las comisiones especializadas
están revisando el texto antes del
inicio del debate general la semana que
viene los diputados en su mayoría de
izquierdas ya han presentado unas 7000
es un impuesto sobre la vida un impuesto
sobre las mujeres sobre los vulnerables
las personas con carreras largas y
trabajos difíciles
en cualquier caso haremos todo lo
posible para bloquearla
el partido de macron necesita el apoyo
de sus aliados para sacarla adelante en
un principio pensaban obtener el
respaldo suficiente de los conservadores
en los republicanos para sumar los 38
votos adicionales que necesita pero
algunos de los derechistas se han echado
atrás e incluso algunos dentro del mismo
partido gobernante han expresado su
preocupación después de que las
protestas nacionales de principios de
mes sacaran a la calle a más de un
millón de personas